good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Tuesday
and speaking of girls that I'll always
choose it's Jax hi I didn't know where
you were going with that I'm trying to
change it up keep it fresh you know I
didn't know how you could be speaking of
me when speaking of Tuesday because I
always choose you that's so beautiful
turdy thank you for that you gotta
welcome how's charity doing
such a good question such a good
question I'm doing good it's [__]
snowing slash raining that's exciting so
I'm wearing my snow boots turdy it's a
chilly day
it actually had chili last night
actually something kind of crazy
happened to me what
so I heated up some leftover chili it
was in this Tupperware
I put the Tupperware in the microwave
like I've done millions of times I go
like wash my face I get the Tupperware
back I'm eating in bed
and I get in bed and I put the
Tupperware on my lap and then my lap
like feels really hot
so I'm like oh man that's weird I must
have like reheated it really hard
literally the entire bottom of the
Tupperware had melted the chili was all
over my lap I guess like I I left in the
microwave for too long or just that
Tupperware was on its last leg like
maybe it was new it was new
maybe it's the brand
Ziploc
that's a brand you could trust
I don't know can you I don't know if
you're supposed to heat Tupperware now
knowing what we know
about Plastics
I just one thing about me is I will
never remember what can and can't go in
the microwave yeah but like what I've
learned recently is that like plastic
shouldn't get really hot because it
could like get into your stuff so well I
definitely ate some plastic transfer to
a bowl
oh so much work might as well just order
in you know yeah but not when you have
chili on a chilly day I know it was
actually really nice Ben is a way for
work and the night before he left he
like made a pot of chili and left it in
the fridge for me So eventually two
nights in a rows that chicken yeah but
then I had to throw it out last night
the whole thing because it was plastic
in it that's your fault yeah you know
I'm not blaming Ben I want to but I
won't but you really can't like he
literally went away for work so he left
you a fridge full of chili he's like a
homemaker no it was so thoughtful we
like we had chili the night before he
left and there was like so it wasn't
like he just made it for me like meal
prep
but I like to think there was some
thought there you know I even though
knowing Ben there was no thought there
he just wanted chili and happened to be
leaving the next day when you say it the
way that you said it he's leaving town
he made a chili the night before and
left it for me in the fridge like
husband of the year no I'm romanticizing
my life
add on top of that he's leaving town a
snowstorm is coming so he made it chilly
the night before and left it for me in
the fridge like it's a Hallmark movie in
the making journey is living in the
notebook I'm living in the notebook 100
um yeah no it didn't really go down like
that but let's pretend we can dream and
we can give Ben a little credit today
it's so important to romanticize your
life we're actually giving Ben a lot of
credit today I know because you guys are
in the Press
oh well also did you watch the episode
yet no I've seen bits and pieces and
then I was going through stories this
morning and organically I clicked a tit
deleting headline about Hilary Duff
yeah so yesterday the episode with
Hillary Duff aired on the good guys they
recorded it like a week or two ago
um I watched the whole thing I was
entranced I have so many thoughts on
Hillary Duff and I feel like up until
this point my one interaction with
Hilary Duff was my famous story in
Atlantis when like I was being a freak
following her around the casino and she
was like get away from me
um but my God she is so normal and I
guess I didn't really I've never sat
down and thought like about Hilary
Duff's career at a glance
she's really been at this for so long
like Lizzie McGuire Another Cinderella
Story Cadet Kelly Cadet Kelly like she
has so many different eras and she's
still now how I met your father like at
the top of her game and just to hear her
be so normal was so and she said like I
know
that like I'm very normal and I know
that people actually still like me which
I'm really grateful for and she was like
I feel like so much of who I am and like
I credit it just to my family like I
grew up in a really normal house and
even when I started making a lot of
money as a kid and like literally paying
the family bills like I never got
special treatment like I did my chores
like everyone else like it was it didn't
tip the balance of the house and I still
like really grew up a normal kid
um and of course she like had some
demons that she spoke about but I also
really respected how like you know her
and Josh are closed so they were like
talking and they would maybe get to a
subject that she wasn't comfortable with
and she was so mature about just like
setting a personal boundary she was like
it came up that she was divorced and
Josh was like what was that like like to
go through like a divorce very publicly
and she was like you know I'm really not
going to get into that but like it was
hard she was just like really healthy
like she just seemed so I don't know
normal's not even the right word because
she was like above normal she seemed
like mentally healthy enlightened yeah
it was really an amazing interview it
was also really funny you know Josh and
Ben are so funny and I think like
Hillary was like what is going on and of
course they ended up talking about food
like the whole time of course
um but Hillary is a foodie that's really
cool it's nice to know that it's
possible to be a child star to be in the
industry to be so successful and to
come out the other side like you know in
a very normal way positive yeah she's
definitely a rarity yeah that's cool
yeah it was a really good interview so
if you like Hillary now you liked her
then like I think you'll learn a lot and
Ben also asked like a question like I
know what I would ask if I sat down with
Hillary Duff but Ben was like asking me
like different questions and I was so
glad he did because I totally forgot her
about her music career
and he was like your music career was
like so and for Ben to know it like it
really was so big he was like coming
clean is my favorite song and he was
like would you do that again and she was
like
I love music and I loved that time but I
think she found like going on tour and
Performing like to be really isolating
and really lonely and she got married
and had a kid right after that like it
was like a response to this like
difficult time for her
um
but I was so glad he asked that but I
also like Ben would never know to ask us
but I really want him to ask her if she
still makes residuals from Laguna Beach
just the theme song the theme song
because it's like now the show got
bought by Netflix like it's it's like
having this Resurgence I've seen
everyone watching it and like it's
reaching a younger demo how does it work
when your song is the theme song to a
show like that I feel like it would be a
one-time payment sort of thing you think
kind of like per season
yeah you know you're not like
a cast member who gets residuals when it
gets picked up that's what I would think
but I know nothing me neither so I was I
was really impressed by like Ben's pop
culture knowledge because he's not one
well compared to us like that's my level
um it was such a good interview and now
they're uploading their episodes uh in
full video on YouTube on Josh Peck's
YouTube channel so I watched it I was it
was so enjoyable well we're gonna talk
about the episode in the fast five
stories because they're making news the
good guys they're making news they're
news makers I'm so proud of them a
little more credit to Ben because we
still have pink lemonade yes on
spiritsociety.com TSC everyone let me
talk about pink lemonade let me tell you
how impressed I was with like the skin
and confidential Community yesterday
like they bought the [__] out of this
like they are die hard and I feel like
whatever Lauren like kind of gives her
stamp of approval on because she's very
well miss focused she doesn't put crap
in her body crap on unlike me uh she
does give a rip and I don't give a rip
yeah but like she doesn't put crap in
her body YouTube but you guys can both
agree on Spritz Venn diagram Society is
in the middle because it's tasty enough
for you and it's healthy enough for
Lauren it's tasty as [__] 6.5 ABV Sprint
society.com TSC it's pink lemonade you
can get two four packs uh it's it's some
good [__] and it's limited edition so
it's not gonna be around oh yeah like
it's kind of just like a distant cousin
that's visiting the rest of the family
but it's not like joining the family and
moving in no it's like it's giving
Eugenie it's giving like foreign
exchange student here for a semester
did you ever
um
like have a foreign exchange student in
your grade or anything
I feel like I can't think of one but I
feel like
that was something that happened
sometimes but I can't think of them so
I'm gonna have to say no I had one in
the eighth grade he came for a year from
Israel and he was really cute and like I
definitely had a crush on him and I
literally remember this so vividly
in the eighth grade we were in lab and
he literally sent me a note I could see
like her dad had a crush on him he like
sent me a note that was like flirty and
it was so gross like it was just like it
gave the ick immedially I don't think I
ever spoke to him again you know who
would never do that Maverick Maverick
yeah I agree and to go for Maverick in
the seventh
this
gross exchange no but he was he was not
gross he was really handsome and like
everyone really liked him but I don't
know like he said this like flirty thing
and he like looked over and like gave me
a weird look I was like I never want to
see this person again no now you need to
explain how is it gross like I don't
remember boy he like sent you a flirty
note and turdy goes Running Scared I
don't remember why it was icky but I
literally I think that was the first
time I ever got the ick like maybe
that's why I think that's why I remember
it because it was like either something
he wrote or like the way he passed it or
the way he looked but I was just like
ick goodbye but I don't think I ever
spoke to him again when you have a crush
objectively so many things that they do
in their day-to-day life because they're
like you know a 13 year old boy or a
picky but you just see everything as
like so sick that they're doing yeah no
that's so true that's also just like the
lens of being young so maybe you were
just not that into him
bro it wasn't meant to be me in the
foreign exchange student it wasn't no
because like you're not good at long
distance no no how would you have that
up
I don't know maybe I'd be living in
Israel right now I would have made
Aliyah you and all your typos over
what's up never no and I do not [__]
with WhatsApp I find it so to be so
[__] annoying and for some reason my
group chat with my friends from high
school is on WhatsApp I don't know why I
think maybe at one point like not
everyone had an iPhone like we've had
the chat for like 10 years so I don't
know why the [__] it is what's up but
like we've just stayed there I literally
never answer it and I never check it
it's so [__] annoying I don't even
have WhatsApp
but it was popping off yesterday because
everyone was listening to Ben on skinny
confidential oh and my friends like
really like podcasts but they obviously
don't know like to the extent freaky
level that we know everything about
everyone and they were like wait the
bosticks own deer media I'm like yes
yeah that's a lot to process if you
don't know but you know dear media and
you know the bosticks yeah and you know
Spritz and Lauren and you know skinny
confidential it's a lot yeah no so if
the chat was popping off yesterday so I
spent a lot of time on WhatsApp
yesterday much to my sugar in speaking
of your friends I was wondering what's
going on with your book club and if
you've read Midnight Library yet okay so
we like dropped the ball in
picking a new book
but I did just start reading the
Midnight Library okay
um I made it 13 spoiler alert
she just died yeah and now I realize I'm
just gonna like go back and have to like
live her life 1500 different ways you
know because she's reading the book
and I just like
I just couldn't bring myself to keep
reading I I got to 13 like a month when
I left your house I read it on the way
home and I never picked it up again oh
wow but I plan to finish it even though
people have told me like I won't like it
and it's really repetitive but yesterday
I did crack open my Kindle to read Lucy
scores sequel to things we never got
over things in which we hide from the
light things in which we hide from the
light that we can only see in the dark
when it is no longer light in which
we're hiding
and it's cute it's not
um
it's not even close to as good as things
we never got over and to be honest I was
like disappointed when I found out who
the romantic interest was going to be
like it wasn't a new girl it was a girl
from the previous book and I like didn't
even like remember her
um but it's good it's cute like honestly
okay I feel like this is going to be a
relatable statement like not to you but
to people who like to read spicy books I
started the book at like 8 30 and by 11
30 like they hadn't [__] yet and I'm
like [__] it's my [__] bedtime
like and there was a couple scenes I'm
like oh he asked her to spend the night
because he was feeling sad like okay
this is it I'll go to bed right after
this nope next day uh they're at this
dinner party things are getting hot and
heavy he Corners her nope I went to bed
I was my sleep takes priority but it's
like [__] just [__] already yeah that's
build it up like you know for sure and
by the way I'm only 30 and I would say
most romance books do not let the people
start [__] until 50 and then 50 to 75
it's [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] yeah because 75 some drama
happens where they can't see one another
by 100 they get back together yeah yeah
yeah oh there's always the low that's uh
yeah that's always corny it's like you
know that it's coming like something bad
someone needs to shake that up like
she's been keeping him or her have been
keeping a secret the whole time and at
75 they're guilty the whole time 75 they
find out what the secret is and then the
other person's mad for like a week I
like a book like it doesn't happen often
where like the bad thing that you're
expecting happens at like 40 then they
work through it and they're back
together by like 60 70 and then there's
like a larger thing that they have to
get through together yeah to take us to
100. it needs to be shaken up Shake Up
Chicago for sure yeah you've gotta shake
it up sometimes um but speaking of books
we recorded the redheads last night I
heard it was I heard the redhead
Community is not ready for this episode
that's what I heard this episode it was
so long it's gonna stay pretty long I'll
just cut out you know
anything I can but we didn't wind up
having like the same conversation over
and over again
um there was so much to talk about like
it's really philosophical like we get
into just like obviously the meaning of
life because that's very uh
congruent with the message of the book
religion
covid like just all the different ways
that this book could be analogous to
real life it was really crazy so
I'm really excited for everyone to
listen to it it drops on Thursday and
this I think is one of our most Buzzy
books ever I've never gotten so many
questions to my email about the book and
so I think it's gonna be a really great
episode that you guys are going to enjoy
so Thursday it's never too late to
become a redhead and if you're not a
redhead start with this book because it
cap five by five percent you're in the
book oh that's nice it brings you right
in that's nice I like that um
yeah so I've definitely I was talking to
Lauren Elizabeth yesterday about how
like I've been in such a reading though
like I feel repelled by my Kindle like I
took my Kindle with me to Vegas I had
two six hour flights I didn't touch it
once like I felt like allergic to it but
yesterday I finally sat back down and I
think reading this Lucy score book will
then get me back in and I'll go back to
the Midnight Library I'm also in the
middle of Mindy kaling's
um
Memoir which is not good which is crazy
because I [__] love her and what I
love most about her is her writing it's
not even so much like her acting or her
producing it's really her writing
um it just feels very uh
like I'm writing a book because I just
have nothing to say check yeah at the
end of the rainbow yeah so it's
definitely something I want to keep on
my Kindle for like you know if I finish
a book and I'm on a plane and I don't
have service okay I can read this Memoir
I'm not gonna finish it right now like
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna choose it on
Tuesday you know no I also was not
feeling my Kindle it took me three weeks
to read the last book I think maybe more
actually the last book I was reading the
marriage portrait which I hated but then
I had to pick it back up to read for the
redheads and that's why I'm so grateful
to this redheads but because it stuck me
right back in and now I'm like what are
we reading next probably the beauty of
girls but because I wasn't reading I've
been watching like I've been caught up
on TV like an episode tonight so last
night I didn't read I watched summer
house
happy to chat about it though I I don't
feel as strongly as I did the last two
weeks so I watched it this morning
because I know that you watched it so
we'll do a little TV recap I've also
been not watching a lot of TV but I have
been like you know investing time into
this Murdock murder right if you want to
recap it I have to take my headphones
off because I will be watching it
okay well it's not like a spoiler
because no it's literally a spoiler for
me because I don't know anything okay
take your headphones off I have like
three thoughts I want to share bye-bye
okay so I watched a documentary and I've
been like keeping up with the trial
obviously that freak did it but to be
completely honest
to be completely honest uh my initial
thought when watching the documentary
and I know this is like I know I mean
when watching the trial and I know this
is like not what it's about but like my
God Alec Murdoch and his sunbuster are
two of the ugliest [__] people I've
ever seen in my life like inside and
outside the fact that like their whole
family has been like murdering people in
this small town for many years
especially like so much so many so many
things about the documentary that aren't
even being spoken about are making me so
sad like obviously right now he's on
trial for the murder of his wife and his
son but like Mallory Beach devastating
Stephen Smith devastating the
housekeeper not them literally like
making money like planning to kill this
woman so that they can get four million
dollars from insurance there's so many
parts of this documentary and this whole
story that are so layered but I cannot
get past
the way people pronounce his name okay
it's Alex a-l-e-x everyone was calling
him Alec which is just incorrect because
there's an X but also because they're
Southern they're calling it like Alec
and like I felt so confused during the
documentary because I'm like who the
[__] are they talking about
um I did feel very conflicted when it
came to Paul like I couldn't tell if he
was like really evil or not like what he
what he did the night of Mallory's thing
was so horrible
and so unforgivable but like when you
learn the background he was like from
this really [__] up family and it
seemed like maybe he was the only one
with a conscience and he drank so much
to deal with that like knowing that his
family up until this point they killed
Gloria they killed uh Steven Smith like
I don't know I feel conflicted about
Paul because I'm so angry when I was
watching the Mallory Beach thing like
the way the family covered it up and his
brother towed the boat even though it
was a crime scene and nobody cared from
the Murdoch family if Mallory was alive
like to me Mallory was such a tragedy
um
and it was Paul's fault so that was like
an interesting balance to work through
but I don't really feel like Alec what
I've been like seeing from The Trial I
don't really feel like he's gonna get
convicted because at this point like the
most damning evidence is the Snapchat
video uh what's so crazy is all the
Snapchats in the documentary there were
so many Snapchats I watched a Netflix
documentary by the way not the Hulu one
um so they have this video Even though
Paul said he was visiting his parents
the hour before he came home and found
his wife and son murdered they have this
video of him clearly at the property by
the kennels like exactly where they were
found so while that's really damning
it's not concrete proof
um and he admitted to lying saying he
was not visiting his parents uh he just
like lied and then decided to run with
it I don't know why
um so while that also all makes him look
really really guilty there's no like DNA
there's and honestly like as an outsider
we're all like oh my God he's obviously
guilty but when you get on the jury I
feel like they play with your emotions
like I could see
some of these jury members like not
like buy I could see a lot of them
buying what he's selling because he's
getting on the stand and he's crying
crying crying
um but what's so crazy and I read this
in the daily mail yesterday
I just feel like the type of family that
they were where it's like they had law
enforcement in their pockets and they
ran this town I feel like that [__] only
happens in movies like I didn't think
that was actually a thing but with this
family it was like they really did own
law enforcement the courts so much so
that the courtroom that they're
currently being tried in
had a portrait of
Alec Murdoch's grandfather who started
this whole thing had a portrait of him
it had to be taken down for obvious
reasons but like that's how deep this
goes and I just didn't think [__] like
that really existed like I really
thought that was stuff that only
happened in like books and movies
um so that was interesting I also found
a lot of the Dynamics in the documentary
about the different kids you know like
uh Miley and Morgan and Anthony
Mallory's girlfriend and Connor are the
one who they tried to frame I found
those Dynamics to be really interesting
so I don't know what's going to happen I
don't think it's very clear whether he's
like going to be convicted or not
um I obviously think he did that [__]
and my God this was just like
my first thought when I watched a
documentary when I was seeing Buster and
Alec I'm like this is the big swindling
you know High rolling these people look
like [__] clowns like that was my
first thought all right Jax I'm done
look alive I'm done put your headphones
back on
she's coming being slow take longer
you hear me now charity okay so I gave
my recap Once you watch a doc I'd love
to get your thoughts of course I just
gotta carve out some time and we'll do a
summer house recap at the end I did
watch as well great okay good if that's
all I believe it is all we need to share
before we dive into the past five
stories that you need to know
and the past my story is that uh you
need to know are brought to you by
Caraway Jackie's absolute favorite my
favorite was on my story it's on my
stories every night that every day I
show myself cooking but I was using it
last night every time I use it I am just
marveled at the science of the non-stick
while also not having toxic chemicals
because for a while we all use non-stick
pans and then we found out that they
were toxic and terrible for us but
Caraway gives us all the ease of
non-stick with none of the toxins it's
so gorgeous and you gotta get it get to
cooking with the non-toxic kitchenware
so you can ditch the chemicals and make
healthier cooking a piece of cake that's
what I said with our exclusive discount
you can now save on the full Suite of
Caraway products including food storage
the tea kettle the mini cookware
their internet famous cookware set is a
staple from any home and it comes in
multiple colors to fit with any design
aesthetic their non-toxic kitchenwares
are all designed for the modern home and
they feature a chemical free ceramic
coating food can be prepared with peace
of mind that no hard to pronounce
chemical compound is going to leach into
your Healthy ingredient all sets come
equipped with easy access storage
solutions so that no stacking is
required gone are the days of misplacing
your Lids that's what you need for your
chili and you won't be covered I
actually we made the chili in Caraway
but we stored it not in Caraway and
that's why I got screwed that's why she
got screwed visit carawayhome.com
toast10 to take advantage of this
limited time offer for 10 off your next
purchase this deal is exclusive to our
listeners so visit carawayhome.com
toast10 or just use code toast10 at
checkout Caraway non-toxic cookware made
Modern today's episode is also brought
to you by seed
seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is a
plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic with
24 strain that have been clinically and
or scientifically studied for its
benefits so
their symbiotic is free from 14 classes
of allergens it's defined that are
defined by the efsa so whatever reason
you want to start nurturing your gut
microbiome there are so many it's
important to support your resilient
immune system especially in the fall and
winter months immunity is on the top of
everyone's mind but what often gets
missed in the oversaturation of
anti-cold and anti-flue messaging is the
role that your gut microbiome plays in
your health
so take two of these capsules once a day
on an empty stomach so it could be the
first thing in the morning 30 minutes
before your first meal it is engineered
to survive your external and internal
environments so their capsule and
capsule via cap safeguards viability
ensure viability through digestion for
delivery of an average of 100 of their
probiotic starting dose to your colon
the outer capsule also serves as an
elegant barrier to oxygen moisture and
heat so there's no Refrigeration
necessary so here's some of the benefits
obviously Digestive Health you know bsds
we love a big soft Duty over here it
also has a lot of skin benefits like for
your skin Health they have four specific
probiotic strains that have been shown
to promote healthy skin and reinforce a
healthy gut skin access also heart
health is another benefit it maintains
the blood cholesterol levels already in
the normal range and it supports healthy
intestinal recycling of cholesterol and
bile
so avoid gutmania and head to the
trusted sources for symbiotics start a
healthy habit today visit seed.com toast
and use code toast to redeem 20 off your
first month of seeds DSO one daily
symbiotic that's seed seed.com toast and
you'd coat use code toast t-o-a-s-t
thank you charity two great sponsors
today love them both you love to see it
our first story some romance news that
we have to dissect down to the studs
Carpenter
step out together amid dating rumors
Sean Mendes was spotted out and about
with Sabrina Carpenter on Saturday amid
rumors that they have been seeing each
other romantically the couple looks
smitten as they embrace the cooler
weather in La while out running errands
together
Shawn donned a pair of blue corduroy
pants and a white T-shirt and a
shearling line jacket for the outing
well Sabrina kept things casual in an
oversized black sweatsuit and sneakers
yeah I will say like I'm obsessed but
her outfit like does make me feel like
this is not a romantic thing because it
would it would have to be early and you
only start dressing like the way she's
dressing when you're 10 years married
like that's literally the only thing
that's making me like it's a perfect
couple you know what I have the opposite
opinion the her outfit is the only thing
making me think that maybe this is real
and not just PR because if it was PR
obviously they knew that the paparazzi
were going I feel like every
relationship that Shawn Mendes is in
except eventually I did believe him and
Camilla were yeah because they were
together for 20 years
um every relationship that he's in
especially when he's like spotted and
then this stage like it's always PR with
Shawn Mendes it just always and he's
such a great PR boyfriend because he's
so successful and he's so cute and
handsome and like okay I'll go out to
lunch with Shawn Mendes for a couple
more Instagram followers why not okay
I'll go to the Met Gala with Shawn
Mendes and pretend to be dating that was
[__] weird right so and I think
Sabrina Carpenter is definitely in her
PR era like I don't think she's above
this right now I don't think she's below
this right now but she's perfect and why
not coffee with Shawn Mendes get a
couple picks taken get a little buzz oh
worst case scenario we fall in love like
I think this is beautiful the publicists
they they did amazing here they really
did but I agree if she knew that they
were stepping out just to get
photographed I think she would have
dressed a little more polished so I
think maybe there's a chance it's real
for both of them like I think for him I
love Sabrina Carpenter I think she's
like extremely talented really beautiful
I think she's got a great personality
like I think he's she's a great girl for
him and for her I love this because up
until this point her romantic narrative
has been this dumb [__] teenage love
triangle between Joshua Bassett Olivia
Rodrigo where she really did not come
out on top like she got dragged so the
fact that she could end this whole Saga
dating literally the most eligible man
in the world I don't know who I love
this more for her or him I really hope
that they can find some common ground
and stay together for a while and even
if this is PR I hope we get more than
just this and we get like
events you know red carpet I want to see
Full looks I I want to see Instagram
pics like keep going with it this is so
gorgeous and fun and harmless that's why
I love a PR relationship it's really
harmless
agreed and it's only harmless if it's
like fraudulent and we got ourselves
like so invested but I'm going into this
with a shrewd eye because I've been
burned before yeah no but I'm obsessed
and it's like if he kind of is similar
Vibes to Joshua Bassett except just like
on a bigger not at all no Claudia if
aliens came down they couldn't tell the
two apart no I think especially like
personality wise I think not at all okay
from my older person's Purge where I
don't know their personalities like
they're both like
handsome brunette teeny singers
literally they literally couldn't be
more different I feel like Shawn Mendes
is such like an alpha and I think Joshua
bass it's like a beta
looks like he's in the 10th grade
okay and Sean Mendes looks like he's a
senior
but they go to the same height thank you
proving my point they go to the same
high school and they take the same
classes
on a bigger level no I don't I just I
don't agree with that comparison
whatsoever
okay
agree to disagree
like it's not a total deviation for her
okay in terms of like hair color sure
and career and like just oh please the
careers couldn't be more different
career interests when she Joshua Bassett
wishes you're really being complimentary
yeah Joshua wishes but like Shawn Mendes
is like you know what he aspires to be
so she just like took you know she's
when you order it online versus when it
comes in the mail sure sure I'm just
saying like
what was I saying
that it's not like a big leap I think no
that it's
I don't know what I was saying okay
I don't know where what I said like five
minutes ago but maybe that just that
he's like Curly headed singers yeah like
I understand what you're saying but I
think they're so different
okay so what
I'm praying you know I will keep these
two in my thoughts that they stay if
it's PR that they stay doing this and if
it's real that they stay doing this
either way stay doing this wait this is
so random but did you see like over the
weekends you definitely didn't see this
Sabrina Carpenter like got herself in
like a little bit of like drama what's a
drama
so she did the BBC live Lounge you know
that thing where like you cover other
people's songs yeah or are you sing your
own songs and it's like really stripped
down yeah so she has a song I think it's
called nonsense
Pop Quiz you know that one no oh it's
like gone viral and it's like really big
and whenever she performs it live at the
very end she there's like a there's a
ver it's not a verse but like she like
talks sings at the end of the song your
favorite yeah and wherever she goes she
changes it because when she's in New
York she's like I'm in New York I love
New York City like whatever you know
what I mean okay and so for the BBC
performance she's like I am doing it's a
bbbc and then she said like I'm in
America where I'm from BBC stands for
something different
what does this stand for I think what
she meant was big black [__] no yeah I'm
like fairly certain
and so like the video got taken down
like it was deemed inappropriate by BBC
oh my God but like when I'm like I don't
think that I never got confirmation
that's what she meant but like what else
could it have okay I'm on I just
searched BBC Urban Dictionary obviously
yes British Broadcasting Company next
[__] be crazy next
big black [__] I believe that's what she
was referring to and that's why it was
taken down for like it's an
inappropriate whatever
but I was like okay Sabrina Carpenter
out here being wild like I I just didn't
expect that from a Disney Queen that's
so
like interesting and do you really think
that's what she meant I don't know but
now we're all talking about Shawn Mendes
like maybe this is like an actual PR
thing so because this BBC thing didn't
really blow up but I'm a freak who saw
it that is hysterical yeah
um okay go Sabrina she's really doing
like she's being so awesome right now
and she's firing out all cylinders
fashion music touring Instagram pictures
like it's just a joy to follow her I
agree I really I really I'm like in my
Sabrina era I was I've been in my
Sabrina era for like seven years and
finally this is like something that I
love that's that's paying off you know
it usually goes the opposite way for me
Little Mix dissolved shows canceled
Sabrina anyone Jackie loves like
ultimately like
gets canceled oh gets yeah for sure yeah
yeah like they're like either they get
canceled their show gets canceled their
career ends something like just know if
you're a celebrity and my sister Jackie
is a fan of yours like your career is
going nowhere
so true it's the kiss of death when
Jackie O becomes obsessed with you it's
so true I'm so sorry or maybe I'm just
it's not me being it's not like I'm the
curse it's just like I like things that
have no place in her culture maybe you
have bad taste no but I don't think like
the culture is filled with good taste so
I would agree with that we're
incongruous that's fair you're loving
the congruent and congruous today I told
you it's always a word of the week here
at the time yes and I think being
congruent or incongruent
is germane to my situation it's a
gorgeous word I really I like it
no because
um uh I like I like it
yeah
are you ready for our next story some
happy news yes Keke Palmer gives birth
welcome her first baby a boy with her
boyfriend Darius Jackson
Keke Palmer and Darius Jackson's first
baby has arrived the actress gave birth
I wish she named her baby true of course
everyone did but instead they named him
leotis and relton Jackson lovingly
nicknamed Leo and she gave birth on
Saturday
I also loved her announcement like no
must no fuss mom baby
name we got gender we got a picture of
the baby in the hospital she didn't you
know no drama
no she's not one for drama no I love her
I'm so happy for her so happy for her I
hope she enjoys this time you know what
time I've been enjoying speaking of new
mamas
um
Molly May
I told you you would the way Molly May
took over my day oh did she what can I
say I love Molly May except yeah welcome
so also just a quick update from
yesterday since we were like still kind
of learning Molly May and Tommy Fury are
not married so I said that they were
married they have a baby together and
they're like in a relationship they're
just not married
um and Tommy is boxing career he went on
love Island as the brother of a very
famous boxer so he's Jordan Rogers yeah
right except then it would be like if
Jordan Rodgers then went into football
and had a pretty good career yeah so
when they were in a great career boost
and Jordan Aaron still spoke yeah right
yeah that's still so weird so weird but
that's I I'm obsessed I actually I don't
know if I will I don't know if I have
the time but I'm interested in watching
their season of Love Island now
especially because like love Island UK
is amazing and I know that if I watched
it like I would be obsessed I just like
don't have the bandwidth to become
obsessed with something else I know I
have the bandwidth to become obsessed
with a couple that I follow on Instagram
and then just want to do a deep dive on
I know and you could like skip through
the other parts oh yeah the other people
yeah relevant except like apparently her
best friend Maura who's the one who
filmed the video of Molly in bed like
waiting to hear the result of the fight
is from love Island so female friendship
that's cute yeah we love love
what was the story oh Kiki bomber I'm so
happy for her I feel like she's also so
funny and I think she'd have like a
really fresh
take on motherhood and like I look
forward to the content and the
interviews because she's just so funny
yeah and she's very honest so yeah I
feel like she'll be able to relate to a
lot of women out there I agree and a lot
of women will be able to relate to her
yeah
are you ready for our next story
Chris Rock will finally hit back at Will
Smith's Oscar slap in first ever live
stream Netflix stand-up special a week
before the Academy Awards after
maintaining the silence for nearly a
year so Chris Rock will finally address
the slap nearly a year later as he
prepares for his upcoming Netflix
special the show which is titled Chris
Rock selective outrage will be the first
ever live stream broadcast by the
streaming service when it airs on March
4th at 9 30 PM eastern time that's
exciting he will also very cool very
cool he will also be joined by Amy
Schumer Jerry Seinfeld and Leslie Jones
during the performance
a sourceful page six if you are waiting
to see Chris on tour address the
infamous Will Smith slap situation the
comedian is waiting to spill his
humorous take on it in his live Netflix
special
I feel like from like a PR standpoint
they're like pushing that he's going to
be talking I feel like he's going to
talk about it very little honestly
I think they're using it as like click
bait but it sounds like it's like a full
Netflix like Festival like there's other
enormous comedians I don't know I just
feel like they're using it as clickbait
and it's like not going to be that much
no it's he's special because it's Chris
Rock's selective outrage I think he
brings out other people I think it's
what he's been touring with for the last
year and so he's doing his set which
included stuff about the Chris uh the
Will Smith Swap and that will be in
there if you want to hear him talk about
it I don't think it's going to start to
finish just like his thoughts on the
slap I think there'll be a couple jokes
about him we'll move on because I think
that's how most people feel about it and
I'm sure Chris in particular he's doing
this historic first live Netflix show
he's not going to spend the whole time
talking about it yeah I do like the
title me too because selective outrage
is real very
um I'm I think I want to watch this I'm
sure you'll be able to watch it if you
can catch it live right like yeah I'm
sure it'll be on Netflix after I wonder
I mean it's so cool to do something live
but like why do it live when you can you
know record it and edit it and make it
perfect I think when you're at like the
top of your game like Chris Rock like
you get the opportunity to like do
things for the first time that nobody's
done like you want to do it you want to
challenge yourself and I'm sure Netflix
pays you more
yeah
this could be a cool Trend because now
I'm like I want to set my alarm 9 30
March 4th like I'll be there a live
event with no commercials
that's cool I like that and it's kind of
something that we could all be a part of
you know it's been a while since we all
watched the same thing at the same time
it's been no the Super Bowl the Super
Bowl and that and how fun was that turdy
oh my God I talked we talked about it
for days on end like I miss it take it
back I seriously missed that you saw
Kylie Kelsey had her baby like not even
close to the date of the Super Bowl no I
didn't even see that I think it was like
two weeks later so cute so cute and this
weekend is Travis Kelsey and Kelsey
ballerini on SNL another event that we
can all come together for yes
country girlies and football fans it's
kind of like us yeah pretty much I'm
excited for that I should uh yeah
okay not that I had plans but I'll keep
myself available I hope Kelsey uh is it
a sketch
I hope so too SNL is on too late for me
I'll be watching it's so late it's so
late I used to wait up sometimes but no
because it's like I couldn't get to the
start time let alone watch it right no
no it's like 11 35 cannot come fast
enough yeah so I'll catch it on Sunday
I'm excited and you know when I was on
tour I actually remember I was in
I don't know where I was but I was in
central time so I had more Humane I was
after my show and I get home at like 10
10 30 and it started I'm like how
delightful is this I watched SNL went to
bed central time is low-key lit
yeah so do people in L.A get to watch it
at 8 30. I don't know if it's live in LA
I know it's live in central time I don't
know if it's live in Pacific time that's
a weird thing about the West Coast it's
like the bachelor Game of Thrones
remember that right right it didn't air
I'm pretty sure like it doesn't air
until that's the time I feel like they
always say like eight seven Central Time
right so they they it's live on Central
and Eastern but not on Pacific that
sucks but
I will say there's a lot of things that
really rock about being on La time like
award shows like we go to bed at
midnight award shows they're done at
eight
unreal unreal also uh if you work with a
lot of people in New York like you
obviously you don't have to wake up at
5am but like at nine they're already
having lunch yeah technically they're
done two three it's true but I people
who like work serious jobs on the west
coast that interface with New York do
get up and start 35 a.m they do you're
right yeah and they go to sleep at like
seven o'clock that sucks it's crazy it's
crazy I've been so interesting the whole
afternoon
Surfs Up man you know Surfs Up it's just
a different lifestyle I wish I could be
someone who could wake up early that's
why I'll never be a true success because
I
can't wake up earlier than I absolutely
have to I actually don't agree with that
and
I don't know if you remember this but
I've seen this clip go viral like a
thousand times when Elon Musk was on Joe
Rogan and they were talking about sleep
job was like how many hours of sleep do
you get an elon's like seven like you
know and Joe's like oh you don't like
wake up at four and like you know do an
eight hour regimen before and he's like
no like I tried that whole thing like
getting less sleep and it's like okay
yeah you have more hours in the day but
you're functioning moronically like
people need sleep and hearing it come
from someone who's like the richest most
successful I was like okay good because
I want to be successful and I I feel
like I am successful and I try and work
as much as I can but like [__] I'm
[__] going to sleep and I'm not
waking up at five but what time does
Elon wake up because like he could get
seven hours of sleep because he goes to
bed at 10 and wakes up at five no it
wasn't crazy like he said his schedule
and it was [__] normal
but then it's like you ever read those
articles Mark Wahlberg gets up at four
does a workout has breakfast doesn't
work out again showers prays and then
start his day yeah no I was just
listening to Kevin O'Leary talk about
his morning he gets up at 5 4 45 I'm
sorry like but it's not because he's
like pushing himself too just like some
people wake up early like I I can't
relate I seriously did some people wake
up early but also there is that like
toxic hustle culture where it's like you
are not achieving your highest level of
productivity if you wake up before six
after six like [__] I don't [__]
believe that no I don't believe that
either but I also you know numbers are
numbers if I had more hours in the day
like if I was you might be functioning
at a lower level productivity I know but
I've also found that no matter how much
sleep I get a gorgeous amount or a
little amount like it's true I'm just a
tired [__] I know I would love to do
like a full sleep study done on myself
like I feel like I get a lot of sleep I
always feel like crap I always wake up
feeling like I've actually been hit by a
truck I would love I don't know if
that's like a thing but like I would
love to be studied
you know they should study you
100 you never met a [__] who gets more
sleep
is it too much sleep
I do believe that at one point yes I was
getting too much sleep like because
really
um I would try and wake up as late as
possible for the toast
so I was getting like 10 hours every
night beautiful and and now and I really
wasn't feeling good now I'm in a place
where I wait I like to wake up now
earlier for the toast I'm not rushed I
take it slow I can watch summer house
before like if I didn't get you know I
could just catch up on stuff
um and now I'm getting about eight and
it feels it on it does feel better yeah
I get about eight my sleep the past few
days has been crap uh I'm having like a
sleep issue I don't know how to
physically sleep without
[__] up my back the way I sleep my
shoulders are at my mouth like I sleep
like
that's crazy like my one arm goes under
my pillow I sleep on my side one arm's
under my pillow so my shoulders up and
the other arm covers my mouth
side
oh okay okay oh yeah yeah well you know
how do I relax my shoulders I literally
don't know how but like my back where is
your head where is your head
um on my pillow and my arm is under my
pillow okay so I actually experienced
something a few years ago that totally
changed my sleep because and a lot of
people do it basically putting the
weight of their head on their arms and
shoulders your head weighs like 25
pounds okay and I woke up one morning
with such a broken arm for weeks it
never went away until I really like I
Googled it I was like oh man I do
putting that much weight on your arms
for eight hours is bad like you really
cannot
put your head you have to think about
the weight of your head it's really bad
for you okay so how do I sleep
I hope your arms down [__] I literally
like I try and put my shoulders down and
I I literally can't like I live
perpetually with my shoulders at my ears
like that's just that's not good how I
am that's how it is a lot of tension and
you know what I'm really struggling with
a lot of tension I would love love
somebody to help me with this and so I
don't have to go to the doctor I have
the craziest [__] tension in my jaw
like I wake up clenched and now it's to
the point where throughout the day like
right now I'm holding so much tension in
my bottom teeth I'm dying to bite down
like it's literally a 24 7 thing now
yeah sometimes when I'm going to sleep I
had to unclench my jaw um I forget my
teeth were grinding so it was something
and sometimes I'm going to sleep I'll
like think about my jaw and I just
opened my mouth I was like oh my God
calm down I know but you get so used to
clenching because you don't want to
smell your own breath
oh that's not why I clench that's why I
clench wait how do you smell your own
breath like I don't want to be breathing
keep that mouth shut you should tape
your mouth that's what Lauren Bostic
does I've actually been thinking about
doing that I don't know I think that
would cause more clenching for me I need
to open my mouth and let the spiders in
no but you're if you're also an open
mouth sleeper it's real that's why you
wake up with like a dry throat or like a
sore throat I don't need you to close my
mouth but here's the thing it's like you
close your mouth you got jaw attention
TMJ you open your mouth you got a dry
throat there's no [__] winning
anywhere no so true everything is
problematic thus bringing me back to my
point I need a sleep study I need I need
a sleep like diagram to show me healthy
ways to sleep where I won't feel like I
was before I got out of bed yesterday I
was sitting on the edge of my bed like
you know how old people like sit on the
bed yeah before they get up and then
they like get up with every limb that
was being like now when I get out of bed
I have to like I have like creaks I got
yeah Squad your crickety cracking and
crickety Kraken is that something I've
noticed about myself that I'm working on
okay good are you ready for our next
story
if it's the story that's brought to you
by rocket money do you know how much
your subscriptions cost most Americans
think they spend around 80 a month in
subscriptions when the actual cost is
closer to two hundred dollars if you
don't exactly know how much you're
spending every month you need rocket
money rocket money formerly known as
true bill is a personal finance app that
finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps lower your bills all in one place
over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they forgot about like
that streaming service you bought just
to watch one show that free trial you
never even used rocket money will
quickly and easily identify your
subscriptions for you so you can stop
paying for the ones that you do not want
simply find the subscription you don't
want and press cancel rocket money will
cancel it for you there's no long hold
times with customer service no tedious
emailing back and forth rocket money
makes canceling subscriptions as easy as
the click of a button over 3 million
people have used rocket money saving the
average person up to seven hundred and
twenty dollars a year okay I did it and
let me tell you how depressed I was
realizing how many especially for the
toast like I try all these these
different services like and it's so
moronic and it was actually really
upsetting to see it all in one place but
I felt like this huge weight off of me
and I feel like I love that it keeps
monitoring it for me so it's not going
to get to a place again where it's a
million subscriptions that you don't
even use stop throwing away your money
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com toast that's
rocketmoney.com toast rocketmoney.com
t-o-a-s-t
thank you charity you're welcome next
story Hilary Duff explains why she
didn't want to be Lizzie McGuire anymore
after the breakout show ended
the Disney Channel Alum admitted she
really don't didn't want to be Lizzie
McGuire anymore as cool as it was after
her breakout show ended in 2004. she
explained while discussing growing up in
the public eye on her pal Josh Peck and
Ben soffer's good guys podcast quote for
so long people were just like Lizzy
Lizzy Lizzy and still now to this day
which it doesn't bother me anymore but
it did for a while I just desperately
needed to be my own person I think that
I thought music was going to be a good
way to introduce myself reintroduce
myself and it was
so she was about how transitioning into
music helps her become more Hillary than
Lizzy and now you know she thinks about
going back to the music department she
definitely wants to do more of that when
she has the time she thinks that she
will I just don't know right now I
barely have enough time to give to my
three children I decided to bring into
the world yeah and by the way her
husband is like a big music producer
he's one of The Producers on Pink's new
album Matthew coma she said like I
literally have like a genius in my house
I forgot she's married to Matthew coma I
know
I thought the conversation between her
and Josh about like being that like
nostalgic kind of icon for young kids
was really interesting because it's this
never-ending balance of wanting to be
yourself
but also not wanting to appear rude or
ungrateful for like the impact you had
on people and the opportunity that you
were given but like at one at some point
like you have to put yourself forward
and he's like I think that's really like
something most people who like rise to
Fame in a like a kids Type of Way
struggle with because you have your
whole life ahead of you and you want to
have a career with different roles and
opportunities but if everybody's always
thinking of you as this one thing it can
be so limiting so you want to shake it
off but then you can appear to be like
you know ungrateful and almost like um
what's the word I'm looking for with an
R resentful yeah so it was a really it
was a very good like healthy
conversation and like very honest yeah
and I feel like like even looking back
on it like she did such a good job of
transitioning out of Lizzy but I do
remember there being a small period and
not as big as you know Hannah to Miley
which I feel like took many years there
was like a small period where she's like
I'm not Lizzy and yeah Hillary stuck
really quickly because she had some
really great roles she put out really
great music and we're like it's the
season of Hillary also what she said was
interesting was that they
only filmed Lizzie McGuire for two years
because they filmed it's only two
seasons but they did 30 episodes every
season and then Disney at their own
discretion would release them so for her
it was two years of her life but it took
much longer to release so she's like I'm
being like known for this thing that
wasn't even a big part of my life like I
did this
for two years even though for us it was
like five yeah
um also what I thought was really
interesting is like she considers like
the scary part of her career excuse me
at Disney's no I don't um
yeah I do
God bless you
um before she booked younger to have
been like this kind of like questionable
she was like I didn't know if I would
ever work again like I was like I kind
of took a break to have kids and then
like when I was ready to come back it
wasn't like it was before and I don't
even think of that but I guess yeah like
what was she doing before I no I do
think of that even when we were talking
at the top of the show the way that I
remember it is like she joined this show
younger when we were working at AOL the
whole cast like came to do that
interview and I remember being like it
was kind of weird that Hilary Duff was
joining this like random new show like
yeah
Hilary Duff is on it I feel like the
success of younger though really
propelled her forward if younger had
kind of stalled and like not been as big
of a show as it was which was very
possible it was on TV Land like no it
was not meant to be successful like why
the [__] was it on TV it was not meant
to be as successful as it was yeah
um I think that that gave her like a
whole new renewed career but
if I thought about it long enough I
would like I would have come to the same
conclusion that that was really the kind
of lull in her career now it makes sense
she was having her kids and she came
back and I remember feeling like oh
Hilary Duff is on this show hmm yeah but
he turned out to be such an amazing show
and she was so great on it that it's she
had like a rocket ship since there yeah
yeah no there was I I just I never
really put in perspective how like that
was like a huge thing for her I thought
she was doing them a favor
yeah no it was mutually risky yeah
I gotta listen to the whole episode
because the clips that I've seen are
awesome she sounds watching she's so
pretty oh my God you have like she looks
so good and she's definitely such a nice
voice to listen to yeah and she like
really thought Ben and Josh were like
psychotic like it was really funny to
watch she's very mellow yeah they are
not they are not I don't want to spoil
like a million things from the episode
but Josh you're like kind of a crazy
[__] fact I'm listening did you know
that at one point Josh Peck was invited
to the Met Gala
and he didn't go why was he invited and
why didn't he go he didn't elaborate he
just says like his it's one of the
things his wife never lets him Live down
when was he invited years ago like Drake
and Josh no no no no no no no
like how many years he didn't say
and why didn't he go
he didn't say either okay now I have to
listen even though he didn't say they
have to do a follow-up episode like just
about Josh and the Met Gala is that
crazy that's crazy because Hillary was
saying how she got invited this year to
Vanity Fair Oscar party which is like
she's like basically saying she's in
this like great season because like
local and Josh was like wow I've never
gotten invited to that but I did get him
into McCallum ah that that is party's
cool very cool very prestigious yeah
cool pictures totally
are you ready for our fifth and final
story yeah because Tom Brady's kind of
coming for turdy's throat
fraternity throw for turdy's throat what
is he doing Tom Brady is trying to
launch a career as a comic
in a last-ditch effort to win his
ex-wife Giselle back now I just want to
say what this is coming from The Daily
Mail that is getting it from radar
online but apparently Tom Brady's Inner
Circle is apparently trying to talk him
out of an attempt to launch a career in
stand-up comedy to win back his ex-wife
Giselle he's a new girlfriend why would
he want Giselle back I don't know not
they're saying that he's trying to get
Gisele back he has a deal for ESPN or
Fox Sports a deal a 10-year deal that he
put on pause for 375 million dollars oh
my God that he hasn't like picking up
yet he said he wants a break from
football these are all the rumors that
they're saying that he wants to break
from football in order to win back
Giselle and I guess she'll be attracted
to him if he's a comedian instead
um honestly if he's good maybe she'll be
attracted to him but if he's bad she'll
get the ick on another level yeah this
seems like uh inconceivable so according
to Radar Online there's recently retired
quarterback wants to try his hand as a
comic in a last Stitch attempt to
reunite with his supermodel X they
divorced last October following 13 year
of marriage that coincided with his
decision to unretire but Tom's people
are not encouraging his new path a
source is quoted by Radar Online is
saying Tom was a terrific quarterback
but he needs to toss this idea before
it's too late as a comic he's strictly a
water boy but that said there were some
compliments for his sense of humor
apparently quote he does a great
impression a former teammate Rob
Gronkowski and is over the top Boston
accent is hilarious
honestly I don't think one part of this
story is true but let's entertain it for
a minute
but it's like where did this this is so
unbelievable like and it's so
inconceivable where the [__] did it come
from I don't know and I'm sure you know
if Tom Brady wanted to like he could
really probably meet with the best of
the best you know get a get a lesson in
in comedy from Jerry Seinfeld like
literally whoever he wanted but at the
end of the day and let's just say this
is true like at the end of the day
stand-up comedy is like either something
you have
or you don't have you can get better and
you can improve your skills but if you
don't have it you're never going to have
it
um and I feel like Tom Brady doesn't
have it because he has it when it comes
to football
you can't have it all you can't have it
all
I agree with that
I don't know where this is coming from
like the fact that it's even here like
makes me consider it because like no I
know because it's so Random of all the
things he could try his hand out in a
million years I would never guess comedy
I thought like honestly I could see him
honestly trying to be like a pro golfer
honestly I could see that yeah or like
wanting to host SNL and do stand-up
monologue and like that's him trying his
hand at stand up kind of like when kids
are like acting she got all the people
the fellow comedians to give her some
tips and and she gave it a shot
what there's no way he's you know going
to the Comedy Cellar open mic night
there's just no [__] no oh my God
stop I actually would love to see that
though imagine he comes out and he's
[__] hysterical
that no it's impossible that's just it's
impossible you don't get that many cards
it's not how the world works it's not
how God works no
I don't know but there are some people
who are like just Excel multi-talented
yeah hello dirty dirty triple threat
comedy singer dancer model
yeah
I don't know anyways we'll keep an eye
out for that one yeah
um let's talk about summer house you and
I both watched a new episode last night
Carl and Lindsay were not in it and
honestly like it was a little boring yep
it was because they're the whole show
they're the whole show I will say I did
see Danielle's side a little bit more
however I also watched her on watch
weapons live and so her and Lindsay are
no longer friends which is so crazy so
crazy it made me really sad even though
up until you know last week I didn't
care about their friendship but
she spoke about Lindsay with respect so
nothing really crazy happened I felt but
it just made me sad like I want their
friendship acting I was such a good
friend to her
I know I'm dying to know what happens I
do believe it happens on camera so
yeah and it happens this summer because
based on I watched the first uh watch
Adam's live up until the first
commercial break which I actually really
enjoyed I thought Gabby's so great I
liked her so much more and Watch What
Happens Live then I like her on the show
like even when she was talking about
horoscopes when she talks about them on
the show I'm like I roll I don't care
but she was being like really funny
about them and Watch What Happens Live
and the fact that she knew like all the
celebrities and what their signs are I'm
like this girl is like this is her thing
like and I think that's cool even if
it's not something I would choose to
spend my time studying like she really
came up awesome I completely agree I
liked her so much I kind of like found
myself like being like rubbed the wrong
way when it came to Danielle like I feel
like she's just like living for the fact
that now everyone's talking about her
for the first time in her career on this
show her you know narrative is not being
Lindsay's mouthpiece she's actually at
odds with with Lindsay and I feel like
she was just like eating it up like
anytime she was asked like a
controversial question she was like
loving that she had something to say and
Andy was like let's play a game now that
you on Lizzy aren't friends like do you
regret defending Lindsay like or do you
think Lindsay like he would ask her
questions do you think Lindsay was wrong
here do you regret defending her here
and it was like everything she was like
yeah she was wrong yeah I regretted it
it's like okay so unscrupled oh
interesting I didn't get to that part
because I thought this stuff in the
first quarter of the episode was
um
how you would speak about an ex-friend
with respect like she didn't have that
many regrets a few she did where she
obviously could see that she was just
like blinded by her friendship but
nothing crazy
who knows
um other than that like it was actually
quite a boring episode and I feel like
it made a great case for Carl and
Lindsay yeah they're the whole show
they're the whole show like that tea
party was boring as [__] why are there
literally two guys in this house I don't
know and all the girls are single like
why aren't we taking the opportunity to
try and find love here it's so and one
of the guys is married right and the
other one can't get arrested right and
everyone like flirts with him but
doesn't actually like him yeah and they
just have these like random guys coming
in the house who we don't know and make
them uh make them in the house that guy
the boxer he was cute as [__] like let
him be a cast mate yeah
and uh Chris's friend Rob throw him in
the house yeah literally anyone just
some guys throw them in throw them in
and you saw Maya and Oliver are broken
up yes and so are Robert and Danielle
well that I knew and then it makes me
sad because they've been together a
really long time me too but
I didn't know Maya and Oliver were
broken up until this morning and again
just the way that all the girl the the
girls and the guys like behave on the
show in their relationships outside of
Carl and Lindsay I just find like so
like kind of not serious so not serious
like the way they're all like oh that's
my boyfriend he's your boyfriend like
where's my boyfriend like everyone has
like these fake Affairs within them and
they like never spend the night no and
it's like oh Paige uh Maya's in love
with Craig and Paige is in love with
Oliver it's like talk with my friends
like how we're fake in love with each
other's boyfriends no that was weird and
that's how you like know that the Maya
Oliver relationship wasn't serious even
though they were together for a year and
when she talked about it on watch
Robin's eye last week like it was bitter
like they did not end well yeah I saw a
quote this morning that said that there
were so many red flags that she didn't
see trust the red flags
I want to know what happened they broke
up in September so
maybe something happens on the show but
she said even the way that they're
acting on the show right now like he
wasn't acting with red flags so right
right then you broke up a month later I
don't know
um I did also really like how Sam was
like really into that guy and then he
did one thing she didn't like and she
like didn't sleep with him like it was
funny actually really likes Sam what did
he do
she would just like she was dancing on
the table having so much fun like was
just being lame no okay I agree like
that she you know she obviously knows
her mind but I disagree with her theory
that she wants someone as big and bright
and loud no no you don't girl you don't
want to shine like and you don't want
someone who's gonna get dance on the
tables with you and then compete for
attention with you like you are this
like bright light you're the star okay
someone who just like loves you and
admires you and is going to be down
there watching you being like Oh my God
I can't believe how lucky I am not
someone out there with you completely
agree two like attention [__] are
explosive yeah no and Opposites Attract
in all senses a grade 100 you don't want
like two extremely shy people together
either you know what I thought someone
needs to send the order back to the
restaurant when it's wrong so true and
software I thought that the conversation
about Amanda and her birth control was
so interesting yeah
um it made me so sad for her and I
obviously like I keep up with her on
social media I've seen especially
last yeah last summer where she looked
so thin and not a commentary on her
weight but almost like um like it wasn't
like it was spiraling like she couldn't
control it
um and I feel so sad I and I hope she
went to a doctor it's I think she's
going to a doctor like in the next few
weeks on the show I hope today she has
like the answers that she needs as to
what happened but that that was like
very sad and alarming yeah and I have
heard
um a lot of people I know who have been
on birth control for a while having this
problem when they get off of it and
wanting to have children yeah I've not
heard of this specifically like I've
heard you know getting off of birth
control it's hard to regulate your
period again it could take a while to
get pregnant I not heard of losing your
period completely oh I have highly
that's really scary I know and you know
what when I was watching it this morning
it reminded me of a conversation we had
on the toast last week about like things
in our house that we just didn't do
growing up and we grew up in like a
non-birth control house so yeah none of
us were ever on the pit hormonal birth
control yeah oh yeah so like when I
would get older and like all my friends
were on birth control either they had
bad periods or they had boyfriends I was
like oh man that's so crazy like we
don't do do that yeah but now that a lot
of stuff has come out about birth
control and I think we're at an age
where people are getting off of birth
control and seeing yeah kind of what
happened and then starting to evaluate
why they went on it in the first place
it's like oh if you're having painful
periods we shouldn't cover up that pain
like we should address why it's so
painful like people are finding out that
they have endometriosis or now just
finding out that they have PCOS when
they're trying to get pregnant like
I I think we do like I'll have a large
audience of women here and I think
that's something that people a lot of
people are dealing with and people don't
realize until they get off of birth
control which is when you get off a
birth control because you want to start
having kids and then you have to kind of
undo a lot of stuff so I would just
consider that because that was a really
sad thing to hear I know oh my God and I
feel like like her voice was like
cracking like she was so sad about it
yeah I thought it was like kind of crazy
how Sam asked that question like she
kind of like a raw dog rip the Band-Aid
off I I'm sure I feel like a producer
told her to I agree I don't think it was
like a her thing but that's kind of like
I thought we're
beyond that you know yeah no it was like
kind of insulting yeah but I think
Amanda was ready to open up you know
because she didn't she could have said
she could have said oh we're not ready
like I'm just living life you know yeah
so I think she maybe wanted to talk
about it but um
yeah it seemed like a setup because if
it wasn't it was [__] nuts yeah it
just sort of came out of nowhere like
they were asking some yeah it was just I
don't know it was bizarre
um so again like not a related episode
but Carl and Lindsay are back next week
so it should be good
I miss them I'm obsessed with them I
kind of am too I'm obsessed like I just
they're like so unbothered yeah and I
also think just given how quickly
they're moving in their relationship
they might have kids soon yeah because
and they kept comparing Carl and Amanda
to Carl and Lindsay and it's like it's
so [__] rude it's like who's gonna
have kids first they said it on the show
live and it's like especially after we
just agreed what we heard about Amanda
like why are we playing this game on the
show
um but Lindsay is older than Amanda
you know Amanda and Carl dated for how
many years before they got engaged
Lindsay and Carl Amanda and Kyle you
keep saying Carl I think you guys know
what I mean but okay yeah it's hard like
their names are the same yeah man and
Kyle dated for years before they got
engaged Lindsay and Carl dated for under
a year and got engaged I actually could
see them having kids much sooner because
they're either serious and she's older
so yes even though she had the eggs of a
20 year old
um yeah but she also does want kids
because she had had that pregnancy
remember winterhouse
um so it's like it's top of mind for her
I could see it too yeah so
I hope that um
I don't know I hope there I hope they
stay together and that it's real and
that like you know I think they will
they're toxically into each other like
for the right reasons I agree
um but when they were doing the watch
weapons live polls last night like I
don't think people agree with us like
everyone everyone the audience I think
is on team everyone not on team Carl on
Wednesday it's easy to be on team
everyone it makes you feel good you're
like oh wait I'm I'm normal everyone
thinks like I do so true you know we're
free we're free thinkers I understand
the impulse to just want to side with
everyone it's so much easier we're
independent thought leaders 100
um so that's our show
it's a good one I really enjoy talking
to you girl I always enjoy talking to
you turdy and I can't wait till we end
the show and we Face Time in two seconds
to talk some more thank you guys so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so on Spotify
iTunes Stitcher public radio iHeartRadio
castbox all the places where everyone's
in the podcast find us the toast even
five star review about a beautiful
stunning and
talented we are hope you guys have a
great day it's Tuesday and we'll see you
tomorrow for hump day bye love ya bye